[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute den american
cheesecake was er gesagt dem new york
cheesecake eines meiner aller
allerliebsten käsekuchen denn ich bin
aktive cohen verrückt kann in allen
varianten ist aber der wirklich das
non-plus-ultra und der allerbeste kuchen
ist einfach der new york ist weil er ist
so cremig und ich gebe auch zu der ist
reichhaltig also es ist immer nur ein
stück dann vergehen paar stunden ist
jahns noch ein stück aber egal ich will
nicht ausschweifend ich zeige euch hier
die zutaten wir benötigen ein mal kekse
die habe ich hier schon einmal im alexa
gegeben
das geschmolzene butter und zucker das
waren die zutaten für den boden dann
benötigen wir doppelten frischkäse
außerdem schlagsahne und eier
hier habe ich noch etwas speisestärke
natürlich zucker vanille extrakt und
eine bio zitrone und wir beginnen jetzt
zuallererst mit dem boden das ist hier
ein keks bunde ist total typisch und
lebt jetzt hier zu ganz einfach butter
und zucker und zucker ist nicht für die
süße da sondern für die konsistenz
später denn die verändert nach dem
backen den boden also nicht darauf
verzichten unbedingt benutzen
[Musik]
mit einem glasboden das schön flach ist
könnte das richtig gut auf dem boden
andrücken und das war es auch schon mit
dem boden ich gebe das ist einmal ganz
kurz zur seite und wir widmen und der
creme ich habe jetzt hier den doppel ram
frischkäse schon in meine größte
schüssel gegeben
denn wir geben alle anderen zutaten
jetzt hier mit hinzu die reihenfolge ist
egal
tut mir nur einen gefallen bei den eiern
macht das ganze nacheinander rührt 1 1
nach dem anderen alle rein
alles andere ist egal hauptsache wir
fahren das und auch ganz ganz wichtig
nicht die höchste stufe nehmen
wir wollen im new york nämlich keine
luft rein schlagen nämlich alles schön
cremig miteinander verrühren
[Musik]
bei der bio zitrone bitte nur wirklich
die äußere schale nehmen wenn wir
wünschen schon das was da rauskommt das
ist schon bitter und dann schmeckt sich
und ich rate euch auch dazu nimmt euch
eine feine reibe wenn ihr diese harten
reifen mit ihr auch manchmal hören reif
für einen salat dann habt ihr so dicke
stückchen drin und dann weiß man drauf
hinterher nach dem backen und das
schmeckt einfach nicht so und meinte
also meinen krebs soll ich meine jetzt
fertig und der ist also die ist ziemlich
flüssig ihr gefühl verlassen aus dem aus
dem konzept weil sie zu viel versprechen
chips in japan ist das gericht und bekam
ich also ich würde so viel mist gebaut
und ich würde darin schreiben geht darum
was meint einig geworden aber was meine
christina aus dem mund ich versuche 8 im
westteil der stadt gespräche also wer
also max ist kein kann ich das okay
die creme ist er halt ziemlich flüssig
gerade macht euch keine sorgen wir
planen gleich ein bisschen zeit ein
das heißt ich gebe das jetzt zuallererst
auf meinen keks boden und dann verrate
ich euch etwas über die zeit bei diesem
rezept
[Musik]
und die cheesecake masse verteilt wie
von alleine weil sie ja sehr flüssig ist
und jetzt kommt das ganze in den
vorgeheizten backofen ihr heizt den ofen
vor auf 220 grad ober und unterhitze und
jetzt aufgepasst die untere einschub
leiste nicht die die ganz unten ist
sondern eben die zweite von unten das
ist quasi so zwischen untere und
mittlere einkommen soll irgendwann genau
drei filme zeigen euch gleich und dann
bei 220 grad ober unterhitze für 10
minuten backen dann rota wunder nicht in
den keller sondern runter mit der
temperatur auf 110 grad und dann wird er
60 weitere minuten gebacken das ist mein
zwetschgenkuchen der ofen liebt der ist
jetzt reif für meinen cheesecake und ich
zeige euch danach wie es weitergeht
[Musik]
new york
okay wer den büchern dieses new york von
alicia keys ich würde euch auf jeden
fall ist das jetzt der kuchen im
ausgekühlten zustand das ist jetzt der
nächste tag
und ganz wichtig damit ihr halt eine
oberfläche keine risse bekommt beachtet
dass das der wirklich im ofen auskühlt
mit diesem spalt offen mit diesem
holzstab damit er diese luft entweichen
kann und die keine feuchtigkeit auf dem
kuchen bekommt denn es kann auch
passieren dass ihr dann auf der
oberfläche sinne ja so ein bisschen
wasser ablagerungen habt und das
vermeiden
und er weist bei mir die ganze nacht im
kühlschrank und jetzt gibt's gärtner
soße damit keine erdbeersaison mir daher
nämlich tiefgekühlte erdbeeren die habe
ich jetzt ein bisschen vorher ich hab
eine stunde vorher raus genommen
hier ist kochendes wasser das gebe ich
es mit dazu und dann pürieren wir das
[Musik]
also wenn euch die erdbeer nicht süß
genug sind einfach ein bisschen zucker
reinhauen und je nach geschmack und
konsistenz könnt ihr dann immer so ein
bisschen variieren wasser und zucker und
ich zeige euch noch meine konsistenz die
ist jetzt so also ein bisschen
dickflüssig so mag ich das persönlich am
liebsten und ich bin jetzt der meinung
dass sich einfach mal gucken sollte ob
der wirklich wieder original new york
cheesecake schmeckt oder warum du willst
du musst halt so ist das leben
also es geht schon als gleitet schon mal
richtig einfach durch das mal so wichtig
dass das pack remich ist oh mein gott
mein herz schon sieht schon mal perfekt
aus und da gebe ich jetzt noch mal meine
erdbeer soße und verdammt jetzt fragen
also wieso hast du keine risse einfach
alle schritte beachten damit kommt man
echt keine risse so richtig gut politik
herunter fließen lassen das ist romantik
also ich will jetzt einfach mal
probieren
also ich mach den test vor der kamera
lies habe ihnen so lange nichts mehr
gegessen und jetzt mein gott wir
brauchen kein kraftaufwand es geht von
alleine
der ist so cremig der ist so cremig habe
euch im infobox beschrieben dass ihr die
sahne auf wahlweise durch creme fraiche
oder schmand ersetzen könnte nimmt bitte
schlagsahne das ist glaube ich auch der
grund dafür dass er so cremig ist nimmt
doppel ram frischkäse tausch bitte
nichts ausmacht den genauso nach wie ich
und dann habt ihr den perfekt new york
ist das austauschen ob ich wirklich also
macht genauso macht genauso unbedingt
und schreibt mir euer feedback unten in
die kommentare was sie mir auch gerne da
lassen können ist ein leid wenn euch das
video gefallen hat und ansonsten freue
ich mich wenn ihr dann beim nächsten mal
auch wieder einschaltet und wir
entlasten euch jetzt mit noch mal ein
paar wunderschöne seen von unserem jsk
auch machen kann das machen auf jeden
fall also bis zum nächsten mal auf die
kiss kitchen tschüss so ich kann mir
jetzt noch mal richtig machen kaffee
dazu
[Musik]
das ist der leckerste koch und hier
jetzt hab ich schwör's hier
du hast noch nie so der kern bekommen
ich schwöre euch das schmeckt richtig
lecker ich habe mich noch nie so gut
profitierten bei dir ich mich richtig
lecker nein das ist sicherlich muss
christian revolutioniert das werde ich
sie habe noch nie so lecker dass das so
gemacht aber ganz gut so